Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier
and welcome to Sort the Court
now in THIS game, I'm a Kiiiing!
and not the king of the squirrels, im actually king of a people,
in a Far Off Land and I have to sit on my throne
-music stops-
I guess the music is done now, okay?
Oh okay there we go, and the  music is back
so I'm a King,
*Mark laughs* in a Far Off Land and I have to sit on my throne,
and answer the questions or requests
of my horrifyingly disgusting people,(That's a little harsh Mark)
and hope to help them stay alive!
and not die!
and maybe food...
little bit, not much, we dont have much to spare
so without further a dEUGH
here comes King Markiplier!
coming in...
Hello! Hi!
Royal Advisor
My lord. I'll help you rule your kingdom, but you have to make tough choices.
Just say yes or no, understand?
No!
I don't get it
Very funny, just give people their answers, okay?
Alright, thank you.
The city's not what it used to be. There were over 250 people living here!
Think things will ever be like that again?
nuh nuh i dont
no
You'll need to be more confident than that, let's get started. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )
*chuckle* Well, I don't know about this!
I'm the horribly deppressed
G- oh god hi
I'm hungry. Can I eat some folks?
I've got plenty  of gold. So I can pay you back for their...
...Lives...(Darkiplier approves)
He's got gold,
I mean what could go wrong?
How 'bout no.
How 'bout no..
Ah, fine, I'll leave them alone
Oh, thank you!
Thank you for not devouring me instead!
Uh jeez bye
Hello, hi!
How's it goin' ?
My liege, there's a man in the foyyyyer asking to join your guard.
He's got an eyepatch, looks a little shifty.
If he's got an eyepatch does that mean he's a pirate?
And if so I want a pirate on my guard
HELL YEAH!!!
What do you think we should do, take a chance?
YEAH! (no brainer to mark apparently)
Course we should
Indeed, more swords will help us
INDEED!
I think I'm doing good!
oh
*strange mark noises*
I was considering opening up a soup shop.
Think it's a good idea?
I'd need some gold.
Aww... Grandma's soup?
It would be CRUEL of me to say no to Grandma!
*Darkiplier intensifies* but I reALLY WANT TO
Alright, fine!
You can open your soup shop.
OHH!!
That was a lot of gold holy shit!
Very well. I will sell my soup in the town squ- Well
-trademark mark stutter-
That was like a quarter of my gold, Grandma!!!
HIGHWAY ROBBERY!
Alright, bye Grandma.
Have a good one.
I guess it's night now.
ohh heyy
*Olden days voice* I was just passing through
and thought you might like some magic
anything could happen(ANYTHING)
Care to give it a try?
I like to take risks
LET'S DO IT!
YEAH!!
ALRIGHT!
This is going wonderfully for me
I'm not doing terribly which is a big change for how my life normally goes
Ok
Thank you
Wow
I can open more Grandma stalls(what!?)
That sounds weird(agreed)
There not stalls selling Grandma
O- or not in that other ways that they would be selling Grandma(Oh god Mark)
No
It's Grandma soup stalls(still not better)
So i did pretty good
I don't know the comparison to do good or bad
I wish to construct a tavern but i'll need some gold fro- YESS
MORE-woah A couple hundred?
*Sassy Mark rolls eyes*
But then the people have BEER
They can get druunk
Yes!
Let the Peo- Oh S#@!
The towns people will be happy to have a- WELL THAT DID A LOT LESS THAN GRANDMA'S SOUP
AND GRANDMA'S SOUP WAS ONLY 50 GOLD!
F*** YOU!!!
*Angry sigh*
Well that's no good that did no good at all
Hello(Jack's Septiceye enters)
It's just... staring at me...
Does it want something?
I hope not
But I'm gonna go with my gut and say that it does!
Yes?
Awww-uh!
*laughing and/or crying* Oh no
I feel unlucky!
But I started out so good!
This game started out so good, and now it's going to take it all away from me.
*uneasy sound* Du-heeey...
Meow, looks like he wants somebody to pat his belly.
nnnnnnnnnnnnNo
yes
No, yes, no, yes, no, yes, no, yes, no
HOW CAN I TURN THAT DOWN?!
*relieved laughing* Ok alright
What, did it turn into a person?!  How did that work?
Oh, no, that's happiness.
*mini burp* 'Scuse me, that's happiness.
Hmph, you call this a castle?
No.  *Sad laughing* No I don't, no I don't.  Noooo.
You should be more CONFIDENT?!
Aww, F**K you!
How's that for confidence, Monsieur Esprit?!
Fine, f**k off.  Oh, hello.
I've got a friend from witch school looking to move to town, could I get a couple gold to help her move in?
Well! ......
Is it good to have MORE witches?
How would I know?  Sure!  Why not!
*excited squeak*  Oh!  Well that was easy!
That wasn't much at all!  Good!  This is going wonderfully!  So far.
'Cept for the little hiccup there.  A LOT of lost wealth.  Well, that's not my fault.
'People are happy and the city is growing.'  YEAH!  The city's GROWING!!  People are HAPPY!
Oh boy!  Okay, that's good.
So now people --- Aww, that's awesome!  Hello.
I got a business proposition for you and your tiny little town. Are you interested?
*Weird Mark accent* Huh this all depends on whether or not I like foreigners
Aaand the answer is yes yes i do
Aha I will bring you details soon
ok
Have fun with your bird on your head
Goodbye!
Oh
*chuckles*
Hi
*still laughing* Oh little Fang
Care to gaze into my magical vampire crystal?
Huh
That seems like a baaad idea
But i'm a risk taker
LET'S DO IT
Yeah
OOOH!
*Happy Mark* I see fame and fortune for you
Yea for risks!!
GO OUT THERE AND TAKE A BUNCH OF RISKS EVERYBODY!!!
Don't do that (Too late)
Maybe do that
I DON'T KNOW!
TAKE A CHANCE?
*Crying/Laughing again* I DON'T KNOW
Ooooh i wish to put on a show. May I have the funds to do so?
How much funds I don't have a lot of funds left.
I-I've got very little, NOT funds
Yes?
WELL THAT DIDNT DO ANYTHING
YOU JUST TOOK MAH GOLD
mew
This cat seems slightly magical
not sure what it wants though..
YES
Yes Pancake- oOh
I guess thats goood, okay..
b- Uh well i mean im doing good on how-
Oh hi grandma.
The soup shop's been doing well
I came to offer you some of our ear-
OOHHHH
THANK YOUU :DD
OH THANK YOU GRANDMA :D
OH THAT INVESTMENT IS PAYING BACK IN DIVIDENDS
oH THANK YOU~
The jester's show was loved by the court
and put everyone in a happy mood
YEAAHHHHH
AWESOME!
Oh thats cool!
We're GROWING! :D
YAY!
This is still good right?
Have you seen my magical cat, Pancake?
Yes, I have!
I patted his bell-bell!
..oh very good i knew he was around here somewhere
NOT SURE WHERE THOUGH
OFF TO WANDER IN THE WOODS FOREVER
helloo
I'd like to build a new granary.
This could help expand our-
...
I don't have much MONEY
YES?
That's all I've got!
ooOH GOD
You got this
You got it. This will help our city grow
Well I du-
IM OUTTA GOOLD
Oh hi
In need of cash huh
I could hook you up if you let me eat a few folks
how 'bout.. it
...
I dO have folks to... spare (o.o)
*scary Mark chuckle*
I COULD sacrifice a few
BUT NOOOOO
I WILL SP- NOT
s-s-STOOP SO LOW
get outta heere
yeah I'll find some other way you go on and get outta here
ok- Hello
hehe
seems you need some gold
I could give you some in exchange for a few souls
NAY
NAY I SAY!
I SAID NAY TO CHESTER I'LL SAY Neuay to you
Georgie
S'pose you'll have to look somewhere else for coin then
yeah I will
I'm just thinking that-
Is that Chester from.. uhhh "Don't Starve"
Hii Chester
what-
what- NOO
WHAT DO I HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU??
How is this in anyway good..?
Well
The people are growing
city is growing still, I guess..
We're doing fine
The treasury is empty, my lord
We could raise taxes, but the people wont like it much
Should we try??
WELL YEAH BETTER THAN THEM GETTING EATEN
YESs
OHH THATS-
AHH but gOOD
Ok
I-its something that we can live with
I suppose
I mean what can ya doo
hhIIII
I was just passing through and thought you could-
-care to try
SURE
PLEASE BE GOOD
YEESSSS!
iTS GOOOOD
*chuckles*
thank you!
thank you~!
Thank you, Travelling Wizard!
You- ohhh
Any mysteries afoot?
I can do some snooping for a small fee
if you're interested
HOW SMALL??
It better be TINY
I mean, I'm not one to trust a Skeleton
But here we go!
Oh GOOD
Okay.
You'll uncover the truth
Thank you
I don't know what truth you're talking about
Hi
Oh!
One of our prisoners escaped!
May I have some gold to offer a reward for her recapturre?
*markiplier analyzes situation*
It's a shifty EYEPATCH MAN
he's not a Pirate AT ALLL
But
YEEEeeeeaaaauusssss???
How much?
AH
FIFTY?
Aww c'mon
Alright.. cool
least I got some happiness back
Who the hell are you?
My boats too tiny to catch fish. Can I have some gold to upgrade it?
I'll pay you back, I swear
*deep inhale*
I trust you!
You look trustworthy with that beard
I can't help but not-
oooooooooooooooooooohhhhhhhhhh god
o- oh hoh oh ohh soo much moneyy
*markiplier cries on the inside*
At least we're still growing!
ohh god
oooo~
did that build agai-
NOOOO
NO
NO GO AWAY
GO AWAY WAY
Yeah you leave them alone chester
You turned evil at one point in your life
Hello?
Monsieur Mouton..
Allo sir!
Are you looking for experienced barbers in your court?
Sure! My beard is growing rather unruly so maybe yes.
Then I shall join you! I am the best of the best
Ha-
Did you assemble your clothes out of
The hair of the fallen??
mmkay goodbye..
Oh
Hello!
Hello Friend!
Sure!!
It turned out great last time!
I'm sure it'll go great this time!
WOO!
Nice!
Is that just randomly generated or is that the same way every time???
that's a good question..
do you find me humerus (ha very funny)
*mark internally cringes at the awful pun he has been exposed to*
Yeeesss??????
Har- *mark starts laughing*
*a very fake mark laugh to please the skeleton*
*more fake laugh*
okay goodbye
alright see ya around
ok..
Some villagers are threatening to leave unless we pay a sum of gold
should we listen to their demands-
NO
SCREW 'EM
I see, we'll let them go
WE DIDN'T WANT THEM ANYWAY
THEY WEREN'T A GOOD PART OF SOCIETY
if they're demanding gold
to live here
then they're not welcome here!
SO SAYS I
The King
Hey and we've got more people there anyway
alright so we're doing okay
Oh hello again!
A caravan of mine wishes to camp in your city for the next few days
Might that be arranged??
suuuure
That'll bring traaade for everybody
Ok byee
OH GRANDMA! :D
OH THANK YOU GRANDMAA :DD
YOU'RE SO NICE!
Ohhh you're so nice Grandma!
Thank you so much!
Oh Hello!!
can you have so-
Of course you can have some food little buddy! <3
Only 2 gold for a happiness!
I'll take that little buddy!
alright bye bye <3
hello?
Nooooooo
no no no no!
I'll getcha next time buddy
Alright sure you will with your
Sassy butt and sassy tail
Hello!
My friend from witch school wanted to thank you for your help
So we made you some magical cookies!
OH
Are they weed cookies? :^)
The sultan's caravan is resting in town
Our citizens have been trading with them
producing a small amount of TAX INCOME
YES!
This is going beautifully!
CooOL!
OH
The castle's almost done in the background-euugghhh
I'd like some money please!
...
Now, here's a life lesson for everyone out there
Never judge a book by its
appearance-cover
say yes
OOOHHH GOD
OH GOD NO
A HUNDRED GOLD???
100?!!
OOOHH
It's slime day, got a present for me?
NO
F*CK OFF
Yeah GET OUTTA HERE
Who cares if it's slime day
I wasn't told about this
Oh yes please
please give me some good magic please
Ohh thank you
Ohh it went well
I don't know how you
magically spawned in more people
although i can imagine how
*gasp*
We've been awarded with a trophy!!!!!
OOOOOO
yaay
okay that's goood
we need to make the city even bigger but it's already at maximum bigness!
Hello~
awww yess
of course i will <33
alright bye bye bootsy
bye bye bootsy
oh that's awesome!
I got so much muns!
ohh that's nice
people are happy, good good good.
:)
GO THE F**K AWAY GEORGIE
gEORGIE
nnOO
GEORGIE F**K OFF
y-yoU WON'T GET ME NEXT TIME, YOU WON'T
what?
uhh
...
how about
how about no
heh
how bout- how about nO
how about a whole LOT OF no
how about- how about Georgie
How about Georgie you go
y-you go away
you go away
back to wherever the hell you came from
oh hi
plants are interesting, don't ya think
I would like to open a garden, may i have some workers to help me?
Yeah sure!
Are you gonna consume them?
Oh god you ate them
sure you'll send them back okay....
awww Grandma!
Oh no you can keep it Grandma!
Have it for yourself!
AWWWW
Thank you Grandma! :D
Thank you!
I l- hey
Reporting in!
I just found a ne- mysterious way to make gold
Wanna know how? Sure!
I'm not telling you!
okay..
thank you!
Thank you!
ookay!
Good, we're doing wonderfully!
I don't even know if there's an end to this game.
I've got a business proposition.
Oh is it just looping through the other stuff?
Thank you Sultan!
I think we got it
I think we won!!
I'm not sure!
Oh! There's a party I'd like to go to this evening
Might I have the rest of the day off?
NO
NO YOU WORK FOR MEEE
Ok fine yeah sure whatever
Go on to your party
Thank you we will toast to your honor
I guess they will..
Citizens say a monkey has been running around flinging stuff at them
Should we put a bounty on it?
I mean..
The monkey's just doing what monkeys do best
But sure
lets put a-
Lets out a price on the head of that monkey
Oh- not kill it?
Oh ok alright that's probably for the best
Oh
Mom says I need to ask your permission to go on an adventure
So can I..? Please, please??
Okay, is your mom gonna come back angrily when you DIIEEE??
Sure, go ahead!
Have fUNN
Have fun out there!
Don't die..
Eugh
I'm hungry
NOOOOO
NOOO
*sigh*
There's a petition going around to open our borders to the neighbouring town
What do you say?
SURE
Bring 'em in, more people- woAH
TOGETHER
Alright, okay I can deal with that
Thank you
I guess
this is going we- WHO ARE YOU
Want me to steal from the rich and give to you?
Not just the rich I'll steal from whoever
UHHHHH
NAHH NO THANKS
Ok byee have a good one
ah you'd probably just- ooooo
you're cute
ehh, You havent been talking to Skelly
have you?
uhh
nnnnnnnnoooooOOoooooooo??
yyyyyeeeEEssss?
I have???
OH
Here take this. I was never here okay?
Okay
Thank you
Honesty is it's own reward
plus a whole heaping pile of gooOOllld
ahhh f**k em
Get 'em out of here we don't want them any way
can't keep them in the town against their will anyways so whats the point
oh
OH
OHHH
THANK YOU
Oh that- You ACTUALLY paid me back!
I can't believe that!
Oh that's awesome!
We're doing so goood~
I don't know what else to do
surely the cost of one sandwich-
NAY
THAT'S MY SANDWICH
and you can't have it
alright fine, have a sandwich
You're excited to eat this..
I'm less excited that I said yes- I gotta start saying no to people
Asked us to form an alliance, should we use them to beef up our ranks?
HELL YEAH
I love some beefy ranks
yeeaaah
More swords for us!
Ok cool
Ohhh god its you
It's nice to see you sir
Do you like my new haircut?
Noooo it doesn't look any different...
yes?
*laughs nervously* ahhh you're welcomee
You're welcome buddy!
You're welcommee
Ehh not you again
It's not slime day GO AWAy
Gooo away
Hi Sultan ok thank you, yes do that
Yeees
NOOOO
YOU EVIL BASTARD I TRUSTED YOU!
eh
Three out of four ain't bad I guess
Hi Skelly
You've got a skeleton of your own you know
don't you find it weird that you can't see it?
Nah, not really
You don't think anything is weird, do ya?
N-not really. Have a good one!
eugh-EUGHH
eugh.. HI MORTIMER
BOY YOU'VE CHANGED
hOW ARE YOU DOING *chuckles*
ohh
heya youtube
hoooh One of your fishermen has been bothering me, I demand a villager as a sacrifice
How 'bout no
nO
You've angered me, watch your back
what are you gonna kill me??
The Fisherman's got my back
Hello
Guards confiscated some gold, can I have it back?
nOOO
You're keeping it? but i stooo..... o ok
hello
Our granary has been infected
how much is that gonna COOSST
Oh that's not bad!
Oh okay!
Oh that's pretty good!
That's pretty good
The escaped prisoner has been recaptured thanks to the bounty- oh okay
our citizens can rest easy known that she's been put away
Is it that theif girl?
The spirits are appeased right now but perhaps we should grant them an offering of gold
I know the spirit world always appreciates gold and it might prevent them from haunting us in the future
What do you say? Two hundred gooOOOooooold?
TWO HUNDRED?
200?!
I kinda wanna be haunted but sure okay
We've got gold to spare
I'll conduct the ceremony and offer this to the spirit world
okAY
alright..
wOAHH hey big guy
Im the blacksmith (found the blacksmith)
I'd like to set up shop
just need your permision
Okay
Go ahead, have fun
Alright!
Oh god not this thing (sam's back)
Just staring at me, does it want something?
No it doesn't, get away!
OH GOD DAMN IT
THAT'S NOT FAIIR
There's no way to win that
hello...
The owners of the tavern are making piles of gold and wish to share some with you
well ain't that lovely of them
Grandmaa!
Can you borrow a coin for the newspap-
OF COURSE YOU CAN GRANDMAA
OF COURSE
You're welcome grandma
Grandma is soo nice, i hope it doesnt turn out to be like the cookie clicker grandmas
where they're horrifically evil
It's that slightly magical cat from before, does this mean we're friends now?
yyEAHH
I HOPE SOOO
AWWW
YEAHH
Ohh little guy
aww
Oh. Hi.
Ba dum ba dum bum bum, yeah you've got
you've got the BEST rhythm bro
you've got the bestest
alright
uhh have a good.. one
The people have started a petition to ban pineapples in the city. Should we do it?
I LOVE PINEAPPLES
nOO
I
LOVE
Pineapples
I love pineapples
I will never give it up
Could i trouble you- oh pshhbpbpbp
I GAVE YOU A SANDWICH BEFORE
you little sack of cra-
alright fine
have a sandwich
You stupid piece of crap
But if you ask me for another
God damn
sandwich
I'm not gonna be too happy about it
next time
God damn it this ASSHOLE
yEAH WHATEVER
ooH
HEY~
OOOOH (thanks Sam)
THANK YOU
Oh who are you?
The blacksmith has crafted me a legendary sword
May I have permission to wield it in the name of our kingdom?
Sure, whoever you are
I don't know exactly whooooooo
but gooood
My lord, a man wishes to settle a dispute. He says he is way cool but his friend says he is not
Do you think he's cool?
Well i haven't SEEN this person how can I-
WAIT
Maybe it's like, something you feeeel
Like this guy SOUNDS pretty cool
But I mean why would he be cool if his friends say he is not cool?
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT
I say you are what you want to be, so he's as cool as they come!
I'm sure he'll be happy to hear about that
That was the most important decision of my day...
Hi Skelly..
I found a way to summon people from another dimension???????
Yea- OKAY
*shrug* alright
okay
I ain't gonna complain
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO THIS WAS A BAAAAAAAAD DAY
eeeee
hHIIi
I told you!
I told you I'd be back!
Your people will be my um.. snack see
How 'bout NO
no
You dare to defy me? I'll eat you ALLL
uhh
This is going poorly...
Helloo?
Would you like to purchase any swords??
Yess
Pleaase
Thank yoouu
Alright
Hello King. I am a tree of the western forest
As you can see however, I have been.. shortened
-actions of your team of woodcutters
My home has been chopped clean through!
In your reckless pursuit of expansion, you have now disrupted the lives of myself
and my other good treefolk brothers and sisters
I demand a compensation by the way of golden coins so we can repair this.. how should I put this
Diplomatic rift
ONE THOUSAND???
WE SHALL GO TO WAAAR WITH THE TREEFOLK
before I pay you THAT money
This is a development which will surely be met with distaste in the community of treefolk
Your refusal to cooperate compounded with your woodcutter's aggression, has driven me to the peak of anger!
Rest assurred, King.
I WILL NOT BE SILENT
This destruction you have wrought on my kin will be known to all!
:(
We needed to build..
Hi
Oho! What is this strange place I have found myself in?
Albert, do you know where we are??
My oh my, Hello kingly person
I do believe I am a bit lost
Might I stay in the town for awhile?
Sure!
It's starting to get WEIRD in here
How nice!
Albert and I shall find an inn to stay in
I'm sure I'll see you again! Albert seems to like you..
Thanks Albert
Hello..
YAAAYYYY
YYYYaaaaAAAAAAaaAY
Oh maaan
Oh thank you!
Let's keep working hard
Okay!
Hopefully~
Oh thank you, trusted Advisor
I'm a good King...
The town we made an alliance with is in trouble! Should we send soldiers to assist them??
Yeessss??
I mean we do have a-
rampaging army of Spirits and Treefolk headed our wayyy
but sure!
Okay!
Of course! We promised
Yeah, I keep my promises
hellooo
Yeeessss
Of COURSE Winston!! <3
People need to stop thattt
Uh-oh
Workers at a construction site
arrived in the morning to find all of their lumber stolen
setting work back by weeks
A tree trunk led a protest in the square against woodland destruction
Guards had to be called in to settle things and they demanded overtime pay..
Papers have been posted around town spreading news of the destruction of the western forest
The people feel quite guilty...
SPOOKY SPIRITS!?
ohhh this is getting baad :(
I don't know how much longer this game is gonna go
Maybe it just gets progressively harder and harder to keep it going
WOAH
Squee, There's a mouse! Should we chase it away?
NO ITS A SMART MOUSE >:(
It's got a book and glasses! Of course not!
Why would you?
Who would be so crueell
Ahh Hello again
Captured some foes on the battlefield
Should we bring them home and put them to work?
As
SlaaaaaaaaaaaAAVVEESSSSSSS????????
Euuughhh eeeeuughhh
Let's not go down that road...
No thank you!
We need to do something with 'em
Shall we ransom the captured foes off- OOOOOO
I like gooollllddd
I like gold~ Okay
I like gold!
Alright!
Sounds good to me! I'm okay with that!
Could've let 'em go free but that wouldn't have been good at all
Alright FINE! I've said no to you, just give me the gold!
They won't even know what hit em-
We stole from our own people but that's beside the point
It's not important
I'm hungry! Can I eat some folks?
Suure we're over populated anywayyyy
You're eating people REGARDLESS
So.. yeah??
Heyyy
oo- that doesn't seem good...
At least they're not UNHAPP-
WOOOOOAHGHHHHHH
Boo!
Give me your gold or I'll eat your townspeople
D:
Noooo????
My GOOLD?
BUT I WANT MY GOLD D:
How many townspeople are we talking here?
I-I Just let someone else eat them FOR gold..
so
are we talking about ALLLLLL of them?
Why am I even debating this? That says something about me that I'm debating this
yeah?
OH GOD
Haha! Yes, I'll take that!
Okay thank you!
Good bye *cryiplier*
Children's dreams are being invaded by ghosts and spooks
Haunting is quite frightful
Oh mann
Sir, I heard about the dragon attack you were made to endure..
I've come up with an idea to strike back
I can craft a blade powerful enough to slay the dragon and take all his treasures
It won't be easy though
I need to track down the finest materials
few hundred gold?
yeah sure
we need to sh-eughhh
Okay...
We need to show that dragon who's boss
My lord! I've come across a- YESSS
YESSSSSS
Oh not enough
I was hoping for more, but thank you
Sir, about the Dragonblade...
yes, thats what im calling the sword now
I've purchased top quality materials, but I need a few workers
YES
Spare all of the workers you need!
We shall have a magnificent blade
And hopefully when we kill the dragon that's gonna be like the last thing we do
Tax the merchants?
HELL YEAH
HELL YEAH TAX THOSE MERCHANTS
We need the MUNS
Oh hello again
I've returned! And not without cause
Prepare yourself for a protest of unimaginable proportions
I am rooted! I will not budge from this spot until you answer for your crimes against my people
Your workers have wounded our way of life. Things will never be the same in the forest
What say you?
Will you first at least admit to your countrymen's wrongdoing?
NO I DONT THINK SO
I THINK WE DID THE RIGHT THING ANNND
WE NEEDED THE WOOD
AND THEN YANNO
YANNO WHAT CAN WE DO?
nnnnnnnNNNnNNNNNNNNOOOOOooooo
By the great petrified pine!
You twig minded sapling!
You're rooted firmly in denial my soft-barked friend
Your refusal to undulge in even the basest of courtesies betrays your tyrannical nature!
Although I cannot say I did not expect this
You humans never change
Always looking out for only yourselves...
Okay bye~!
IT'S FINALLY DONE!
I've finished crafting the Dragonblade
All we need now is somebody to wield it!
I'll spread the word to our heroes. If they wish to take up the blade I'll send them here
Can we KILLEM
ooo
I'm baack
Alright sure! But you're not gonna take my Dragonblade
You're not!
Don't you dare!
My Lord! Might I be the one to take up the Dragonblade and slay the dragon?
YES! YOU MY FRIEND ARE GOOD
You're gonna do it, you better do it
y-y-you frikin better- oh
Hello!
o.o
YEAH I CAN
SURRE
Give me all of your exposed wires and I'll fix you right up
I am become fixed
You are not smart, but you are robot
Ok..
Oh, HEY
I'm truly sorry about earlier. My circuits weren't quite fried
my circuits WERE quite fried
I offer my thanks for your help
Thank you!
oooo Quite logical
Thank youuu
Have a good one
Oh, hello Anabelle
Abeille
Bonjour! Just finished moving in
An assistant of my own. May I have one person
Sure, but why do you need an assissssssss
tant
WHO ARE YOU
The Council of Science has devised a blueprint for a gold-generating machine
It will take time to construct and many resources
but if the calculations-
produce gold steadily for the rest of eternity...
FIVE HUNDRED GOLD I DONT HAAAVE 500 GOLD
If i was more a- You're not even gonna say anything as you walk away
*gasp*
YEEEEEEEEEEEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHH
ALRIGGGGGGGHHHHHHHHT
WE DID IT!!!
SCIENTIST COME BAACK
Oh man we finally did it!
Ok
That is the end of
Sort the Court- Hi
I- uh
NO IM NOTT
GOO AWAY
Ok so
That is the end of Sort the Court
I've been playing this for about an hour
I don't think there IS an end to this game
But if there IS
maybe you can find it on your own
you can play this game for yourself
through the link in the description below!
And let me know what you thought of it!
It's kind of a cool game
It was made for the Ludum Dare Game Jam
and not too bad
So thanks again
And as always
I will see you
in the next video!
Buh-Bye!
*outro*